six two kennesaw did he advise what van
i got three white vans
i got three so
tearful i got three white vans nobody's
come out of them
10 22 i got contact what's up man
okay what's up uh basically we went in
there purchased some food um
i guess there's something wrong with
their server okay before us tried to
order on the little box thing she said
that wasn't working he had to stop us
from ordering go help her okay so he
probably frustrated that word
that's the whole scenario
so why'd y'all call so like what
happened because
we ordered the food um he couldn't print
us a receipt okay um so he said the
receipt would be printed in the back so
i said okay so he said that me and my
fiance looking for homes around here so
we went back to progressive reynolds
looking at homes uh-huh um i guess our
order was called but we don't even know
our order number okay you know i'm
saying so now our food is sitting there
cold so when i come up i say you know i
try to fry the fries or they'll loop
warm but they're not hot okay saying so
i just asked him can we get some fresh
fresh fries okay he said okay the fries
are not hot touch the fries they said no
they're not hot and at this point you
don't touch them so you know yeah i
didn't get a fresh set okay so is he
getting the fries and i said can i also
get the receipt that was five minutes
ago yeah you know what i'm saying he
excuse me sir five minutes ago i can i
can run my store however i want to run
my store disney
i didn't pay he said matter of fact you
can leave my property get off my
property now or you can come and get uh
i do a refund i say sir wait we um cash
up card just three to seven business
days to do a refund just give me my set
of fries in my receipt that's what
you're supposed to do anyway when i pay
for my order okay this is not my my
story
this is his business he on this like
it's not hard
the fries in the burger okay give your
id on you no sir okay i'm gonna have to
get your information okay
what's your last name
s-i-m-s s-i-m-e-s yes and first name
a-n-t
o-i-a-n-e-a-n-t-o-i-a-n-e
what's your birthday
what's good telephone number for you
all right so i'm going to let you know
he caught as well so y'all both called
yeah
so i'm going to go in and talk to him um
hey kron will you hang out with him
all right he's gonna hang out with you
for a second okay i'm going to talk to
him real quick
yeah
let's go inside let's talk inside
outside of here
somewhere i don't want i don't want us
to be outside talking
we can talk right here we can go inside
it don't matter so what happened dude
okay so break it down for me okay
he insists that he's all his food is
cold okay he's burning my hands some
whatever that's you know not you know it
doesn't really matter okay take the next
holster
you better give me a
fresh five months
what
here's a little old lady and she just
came up to us if you even
but he
starts losing it starts shoving his food
at me
and i said sorry you should actually
tell you what you can take your business
elsewhere give me a call i'll give you a
refund no you're not going to give me an
effort refunded you give me food and my
money back okay look sorry got shoved
his food i took his food so he's got
nothing to show with me because next
thing you know he's throwing his drink
at me so i took his food and took a
little spray put it in the trash
here's your give me your card now get
your refund take your business elsewhere
please don't come back okay scream at me
i want ct you know did you give him his
refund like is that all right you
refused to
give you
okay
no your price is the way he was talking
okay so i don't want to see you i want
to ever have him back okay dudes
obviously on probation got an ankle
bracelet on okay what is um your
information too
if you have your id that'd be much
easier
perfect
and
uh i mean i've been around for over a
year i just i don't think i've ever met
you did you just take ownership or i've
been around since 2011. okay you're
usually up to jobs right gotcha gotcha
what's a good telephone number for you
and you have to have his card to do a
refund
yeah
yeah i don't know
okay if you want to give me a card i'll
give you this refund okay
or you're not to give them any more food
you're not going to like remake yourself
okay i mean that's your business you're
right i'm just asking
i told him it's my business
okay
all right
i'll be right back
eleven six two kenneth hall can you run
one name and date of birth
last name sierra india mike ekko sierra
first name alpha november tango oscar
india alpha november echo
bravo mike
all right so here's the deal
as a business owner he has the right to
not remake your food
he is willing to do a refund he has no
problems doing a refund but he's not
going to remake your food
as a business owner he can do that
um he does not want you coming back in
the store he actually wants us to
currently trespass you so you will not
be allowed back at this mcdonald's i
don't even stay here
it doesn't matter he's requested it we
got to do it it's not a big deal it's a
piece of challenge no we're not charging
it's a piece of paper we're going to
give you that's going to say hey you
can't come back to this mcdonald's
that's all it is
wow like yeah no just like just
realistically did i do anything i don't
know i i'm not here to even figure that
out i'm here i'm here to keep the peace
yeah this is completely civil so yeah
yeah okay yeah about it later on i don't
want to complain about it um
no no
i just i'm just don't understand what i
did wrong with this no you're good um do
your ct forms
okay i have cd4 that's fine um it's not
a big deal
so look all right so this is civil okay
as a business owner he has the right to
refuse service to anyone he chooses to
refuse service to just like if you own
the business you have the same right to
do the same thing do you own the
physical business like you do have
whatever you can ct you can ct whoever
the hell you want you can do whatever
as long as it's within the law and
that's within the law okay all right so
hang out with him i'm gonna get that
form it's a simple form that says hey
just don't come back to this mcdonald's
now i'll tell you if you do come back to
this mcdonald's we'll get caught out
here
you go i'm not all right i'm gonna i
gotta smart so
um you cool with the refund
uh yeah so i just gotta go in there and
yeah i will get that in just a second
okay okay
go ahead
careful
52 14 and 17. the call figures now am i
with the female that says seven assholes
and the daughter is inside with her door
violence armed and dangerous
well let me show english 2013
he's being slick over here he's got a
big damn ankle monitor i got you i know
i gotcha
uh no you're good
thank you
oh um he's gonna do the refund so i'll
get you the card here in a second okay
license status
suspended 24 year old male 1 wanted
person caution
violence
armed and dangerous
11 16 11 16.
suspended 24 year old
what's your eta
10 462 kennesaw looks like we just found
the same id
you go ahead and confirm that
384 522 okay
oh
all right spell your um last name for me
s-i-m-e-s okay
um where's your driver's license out of
i don't have it okay i think my mother
said
okay
yes i am especially your first name
again a-n-t-o-i-e
okay
so i'm basically just banned from here
correct not kennesaw
um
his name
their name i can't remember how he's got
new form so i don't know
name
take it any higher you call it
yeah nah this is just 10 10 bucks
i don't know yet
what's the address here
like that
sorry man
so
there's possibly a 10 for 10.99
2049 caught parkway
we got it
yeah i got it
yeah
give me a second
excuse me so there's no exceeding or
nothing like that no yeah
yeah no i'm going to get him to fill
this up
okay just whatever huh
yeah that's what i'm thinking
all right mr sims come over here have
you signed this
i'm not under arrest
no sir there should come over here i'll
have you sign this real quick i said i'm
not under arrest no no you're not going
to try yeah just come over here maybe
sign this real quick you have to decide
and saying that you're going to come
back to the property so you'll fill this
part out can i see you sir yeah here you
come over here no i'm i'm afraid of
y'all where are you from three years sir
i'm afraid all right i'm i'm gonna walk
you through why are you doing that i
know how to fill it up why are you doing
that i know how to am i all right yeah
car car car car
six innocent cop
[Music]
[Music]
huh
i fell too